COLT MCANLIS: You
know, compression
has always had a warm
spot in my heart.
It's kind of this weird
place where data algorithms,
and information
analysis, and performance
all mix in the middle.
In reality, a lot of programmers
have allowed compression
to pass them by.
It's sort of a lost art.
With most algorithms out there,
like JPEG, ZIP, and everything
else, people are
content to just let
data compression be
someone else's problem.
But it's an amazing science,
an amazing suite of algorithms.
And more people should
have compression
in their programming toolbox.
There's 5 billion human
beings on the planet who
still don't have
broadband connectivity.
And for these individuals,
getting them on the internet
and having them have the
same sort of access to data,
and the same abilities, and life
process that comes from that,
is actually cost prohibitive.
Man, if you want to look
at the next 10 to 15 years
of computing and
adoption in the world,
compression's going
to be right there
at the middle of all this,
making it all happen.
For something as complex
and as deep as compression,
we got to find a different way
to teach people the problems.
The audience for Compressor
Head is every programmer.
It doesn't matter if you're
writing application software,
web apps, mobile apps,
you care about data.
And you need to know how
to manipulate, understand,
and analyze your data
to make it as small
and cost efficient as possible.
It doesn't matter if you're
a beginner, intermediate,
or a professional.
There's something in this
video series just for you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]